That’s right. It’s time once again to
activate the famed Anom-O-Tron 600,
our patented machine that definitely
wasn’t developed in affiliation with
Doctor Wondertainment. We swear. After
recalibrating, rebooting, and hitting restart,
our infamous specialized supercomputer is
ready to bring you all manner of improbable
scenarios. We’ll simulate encounters between
the SCP Foundation’s various anomalies,
and any other character from any other
universe you could possibly imagine.
Here’s a question for you: what do you think
would happen if SCP-096, the notorious Shy Guy,
ran afoul of someone he couldn’t just kill
for daring to look at it? What if the scourge
of the underworld, battler of demons, and the
Devil himself, set his sights on SCP-096? Well,
we’re about to hit the button and discover the
outcome of SCP-096 vs The dreaded Doom Slayer!
So, you’ve heard the old philosophical debate
about a tree falling down in the woods,
and whether or not nobody being around to
hear it brings into question if it actually
happened at all, right? Well, let’s reframe
that one a little. If an interdimensional rip
in the very fabric of the time-space continuum
opens up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it, does a
six-foot-tall, three-hundred-and-sixty-pound
hulking killing machine still emerge
to slaughter everything in his path?
It turns out, yes; yes, he definitely does.
Horrified screams and the loud bang of shotgun
blasts rang out through the hallways as Foundation
researchers ran for their lives. The Doom Marine
had just been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar environment.
Mere minutes earlier, he had been awakened
inside a sarcophagus within a facility on Mars,
in the year 2148. Unfortunately, Doomguy
hadn’t had the best start to his day given
that the base he’d woken up in was being
overrun by the forces of Hell itself,
thanks to a rogue scientist opening up portals
to the underworld and allowing all manner of
demonic abominations to come pouring through.
So, naturally, when another portal brought the
armor-clad demon slayer to a site run by the SCP
Foundation, the intensity of battle had led to
the Doom Slayer believing the unsuspecting staff
were actually all demons in disguise. And to him,
the only good demon is one he got to send back
to hell in the most brutal fashion imaginable.
He wasn’t going to stop until he’d torn through
wave after wave of Foundation personnel, thinking
perhaps if he killed enough, he’d be returned
to his previous locale for more demon killing.
As the Foundation dispatched its security
forces and Mobile Task Forces to take down
the unstoppable force of carnage decked out in
head-to-toe green armor, it seemed nothing they
could throw at the Doom Marine was enough to
take him down. A hail of bullets rained down
on him from the MTFs’ weapons, ricocheting
ineffectually off his protective plating as
he continued his assault, remaining tireless
thanks to his immense physical conditioning.
The SCP Foundation tried and failed to contain
Doomguy. They had assumed him to be either a new,
undocumented anomaly or a violent and unhinged
maniac from the Church of the Broken God, given
his armor resembling cybernetic augmentations and
machine parts grafted to his body, along with his
arsenal of advanced weaponry. But there were
no enhancements, no augmentations made to the
Doom Slayer; he may have once been mortal,
but centuries of killing demons had allowed
him to transcend ordinary human physiology. He
didn’t tire, never lost strength, never needed
to eat or drink, and was near enough immortal.
Yet, among all the chaos that was unfurling,
a solitary researcher had just managed to slip
out of the Doom Slayer’s reach. He ran as fast
and far as he was physically able; the Mobile
Task Force troops were getting eviscerated,
the Slayer could easily tear through the
whole Foundation. Then, fleeing for his life,
the researcher had an idea: either a stroke of
genius or total idiocy, and a risky move either
way. He’d set an anomaly on the Doom Slayer.
He turned to the nearest containment cell,
a windowless room with a heavy, locked door.
Hurriedly inputting his security clearance code,
the researcher heaved the door open and
covered his eyes with his arm. It wouldn’t
have been his first choice of SCP to send into
battle, but SCP-096’s cell was the closest.
Lumbering out of its containment chamber on
its misshapen, elongated legs, SCP-096 scanned
the area. Alarms were blaring, it was loud and
frightening to the timid, albeit terrifying
creature, that reached up to cover its ears in
bewilderment. Not that the researcher who had
freed it could see what it was doing. For one,
his eyes were still covered. And for another,
he was already dead, thanks to the Doom Slayer
barging shoulder-first through a nearby wall and
raining debris on the nearby researcher.
Beneath the visor of his helmet,
the Marine breathed heavily, panting
but not tiring as he looked at the pale,
skinny creature in the corridor before him.
It was clutching the sides of its head;
its huge jaw hung open. As far the Slayer knew,
he was making progress; his attack was working.
He’d killed enough of these demonic imposters
that they were starting to reveal their true
forms. Although, in all his years of bloodshed
and being a scourge to the denizens of Hell,
he hadn’t quite ever seen a demon that looked
like the Shy Guy. Not that it mattered to Doomguy,
before long, it’d be dead like all the rest.
The towering, stick-thin creature turned
to face the armor-adorned warrior and
shrieked, immediately overcome with anguish,
having a full-blown breakdown as it often did
whenever someone looked at it. As the demon
killer stomped down the corridor towards it,
The Doomblade, a long, sleek razor sharp edge
extended from the Slayer’s gauntlet where it
was mounted on his wrist. He reached down and
yanked the rip cord on his chainsaw too
– he was long overdue for a glory kill.
But before he could strike at SCP-096,
the Shy Guy moved with impossible speed,
faster than even the Doom Marine himself.
It zipped behind the encroaching Marine,
moving quicker than he could perceive: one second
SCP-096 was crying and wailing in front of him,
then not even a full second later the creature
was towering over Doomguy from behind.
SCP-096 gripped the Doomblade and snapped it with
ease, like breaking a twig before reaching its
other long arm down and pulling the chainsaw
from Doomguy’s hand. The motorized blade was
still running as it clattered to the ground,
cutting a hole through the floor and falling
down into the lower level of the facility.
Enraged, as he very often was, the Doom Slayer
reached both arms back behind his head and gripped
the elongated torso of SCP-096. The virtually
immortal killing machine hurled the creature
over his head with ease; thanks to his immense
strength, Doomguy could lift objects far heavier
than most ordinary humans, and carry heavy weapons
without tiring. He had even grappled hand-to-hand
with demons. Throwing the Shy Guy down the
corridor like hurling a basketball was no trouble
for the spacefaring slaughterer of Satan’s spawn.
Screaming and howling in pain, SCP-096 crashed
to the ground at the far end of the corridor,
tumbling over itself thanks to its long limbs
before landing in a confused heap. As the Shy
Guy reoriented itself, struggling back onto
its feet and standing up at its full height,
it was instantly knocked back as
the force of something struck it.
Baring down on SCP-096, the Doom Marine charged,
his signature double-barrelled, sawed-off shotgun
drawn. It was hardly leaving a scratch on
SCP-096’s pale skin, despite the moderate
amount of damage the weapon was capable of. Two
shots would ring out, reeling the creature but
not harming it. Then, by the time SCP-096 managed
to recover from the blast, the Slayer had finished
reloading in time to open fire yet again. Even as
the Doom Slayer raced nearer, closing the distance
between him and what he thought to be another
demon for him to kill, the shotgun seemed to have
little effect against the Shy guy at close range.
Stowing the weapon, Doomguy put all of his
focus and energy into his charge, heavy boots
stomping against the ground as he raced towards
the Shy guy, still stunned by the last shotgun
blast. Before the creature could steady itself,
this time it was struck by another force,
a heavy object barrelling towards it. The
Doom Slayer shoulder barged SCP-096, sending the
pair of them crashing through the nearest wall.
They burst into a neighboring room, with the Doom
Slayer keeping a single-armed grip around the Shy
Guy while repeatedly delivering vicious punches to
its gut with his other hand, not once relenting.
SCP-096 screeched in pain, clawing at the Slayer
but unable to tear through his impenetrable armor.
As they crashed through yet another wall, SCP-096
did something it rarely ever did. In fact, maybe
something it had never ever done before. It ran
away from someone that had looked at it. While the
creature was deeply insecure and so self-conscious
that it would kill anyone who saw so much as a
photograph of it, it didn’t often feel afraid.
But the Doom Slayer, this muscle-bound killing
machine that had brutally butchered actual demons
was so imposing, so threatening, and so effective
at dispensing painful punishment, that he scared
the fight out of SCP-096. Sobbing with terror, the
creature zipped away using its anomalous speed,
trying desperately to put as much distance between
it and the Doom Marine as it possibly could.
But therein lay the problem. No sooner had
SCP-096 gotten away from the Scourge of Hell, then
the creature immediately felt the familiar pull.
Whether it was an inescapable compulsion to kill
everyone who looked at it, or a fact of the Shy
Guy’s biology, it could only distance itself from
the Slayer for a few seconds before it reappeared
near him. From Doomguy’s perspective, it seemed
the creature was intentionally disappearing and
reappearing using its teleportation-like
speed to evade a volley of his attacks.
SCP-096 came at him again, stuck in a loop of
trying to attack the Doom Slayer for looking
at it, to immediately regretting that course
of action and fleeing in fear of its hulking,
heavy weapon-toting target. Doomguy
drew every weapon he had in his arsenal,
launching a barrage of high explosive ordinance
from his rocket launcher to try and kill SCP-096.
The resultant damage practically reduced an
entire wing of the Foundation site to rubble,
but still couldn’t kill the Slayer’s opponent.
Meanwhile, in the moments that the Shy Guy
temporarily forgot his own fear for the Doomguy,
it managed to rush towards him, swiping the
Marine’s various technologically advanced
armaments out of his hands before instantly
remembering why he was so scared of the green
armored force of destruction and dashing away.
Doomguy’s supply of weapons had all but
been depleted, neither he nor SCP-096
were getting tired out by their constant back
and forth. They were locked in a stalemate,
until the Shy Guy tried to get back to its cell.
Zipping away once again, it cowered in the corner,
reaching for an old, worn-out paper bag that it
slipped over its head. It sat down, trembling,
rocking back and forth in a fetal position.
The Shy Guy was terrified, an overwhelming,
debilitating fear gripped it… fear that
became pure dread as the sound of heavy
boots began to stomp closer and closer.
Kicking the steel door off its hinges,
the Doom Slayer walked into SCP-096’s cell,
carrying something huge in his hands. It was
one of the most devastating weapons Doomguy had
at his disposal, capable of unleashing untold
destruction: the BFG 9000. Without remorse, not
caring that the creature seemed to have retreated
and was cowering away from him, the Slayer raised
the powerful weapon and fired an enormous ball of
green energy. The blast engulfed the entire room,
tendrils snaking out from the energy projectile
causing additional damage to the surrounding
area until… there was nothing left of SCP-096…
Now for another showdown brought to you through
the Anom-O-Tron 6000 go and check out “MANDALORIAN
VS SCP-610 THE FLESH THAT HATES” and “COULD
HOMELANDER’S EGO CRUSH THE SCP FOUNDATION?”
to see a super-powered psychopath go
up against the Foundation themselves!